I love a good chase I mean these days
we've got a lot of sophisticated
equipment at Hardman's a camera a fatal
er camera cranes a custom-made pan until
it has motion control equipment and we
can do all sorts of things but em it
really comes back down to the basics and
I think this actually shows the basics
we had very very little equipment then
we had some quite basic motion control
of women we could do weekly little
tracks for the camera we could just
about computer control things and
initially we did we actually tried to
sequence that when we saw the storyboard
and put together and we talked about
this wonderful chase it was going to be
um we tried some with a nice linear
camera track and some smooth movements
and it was rubbish
it had no excitement it had no no
tension to it em so went back to basics
again we had a set a typical set in
there was about a 15-foot set which was
which was basic the wallpaper just
repeated I think we photocopy didn't we
have a painted carpet bits of props in
there we built a camera sort of crane a
camera jib we had an old camera dolly
we've got the wheels off that some old
camera tracks I keep saying old most of
our gear was from an antique shop piece
together we mounted the camera on this
camera jib hanging over the set there's
a little railway line running down the
sets with a train on it and we had our
character list let's use Sean for the
meet justice you can stand in for
grommets the minute he's in the wrong
position so we would have the camera
pointing at our character here our sat
on the train now either pulling him
along or pushing him was a rod just out
of out of vision so if you mentioned the
framings there so there be a rod pulling
him and as you push the camera along
he'd move or vice-versa he could push
him along there we would do it on time
exposures the goosing about stop stop
frame we can choose our own exposure
speed and we had I think there's like a
two-second exposure you're marked out on
the camera track little 3 3 inch there's
markings on there
so the animator would go in there he'd
animate the character step back he'd
start pushing the camera as he as he
pressed the shutter so over the two
seconds he'd move it along three inches
now because the characters moving with
the camera it remained in focus
just a perhaps and the background was
blurred so that was one of the first
principles really it's a nice it's
organic and it didn't cost very much to
him now the other thing about it on the
test there hadn't really laid the tracks
down properly it was all a bit shaky
it's all the old equipment there so when
the test came back it was shaky it was
saying all sorts of things some frames
he was bouncing around some frames is
out of focus but that of course is what
made it that's what made it exciting it
was organic and he's fast I think he
we're gonna have to put the tracks down
properly and do us all sorts of things
but no this is it this is the method and
be honest we've actually kept that
method most of our films